the Joe Rogan experience I did a spot up
in the belly room did you really get out
of here did you where's your name on the
wall get out of here well that's the
thing right anybody you up in the belly
room if it's one of those weirdo shows
weirdos hey man that's how people get
started I started a show there that got
picked up it's coming out next month
what is it in March
yeah it's the show that we got already
laughing because we started it two years
ago in the belly room what is it it's
called
what was called stand-up to the streets
and then he end up to the street yeah it
was a dance battle you know Rochelle
yeah and so we started at two years ago
my friend Justine Moreno and the first
day we were supposed to do it
you actually bumped us out I don't know
you're just like I'm doing tonight we're
like ah damn it Joe wins again nobody
told me no no of course not but then
comedy sir must have just offered it to
me I think they did but then we did it
like monthly we go every month we went
in there and did it sold out every night
and then this network was like hey let's
put this on TV and notionally out March
what's it on it'll be on the E Network I
was hoping you didn't say Bravo well
same thing
[Laughter]
isn't that what Keeping Up with the
Kardashians that you're lead-in oh no I
don't life is in the Jimmy other day
watching that no walked and I go why
yeah you're smart yeah you're
interesting what are you doing mm-hmm
she likes being distracted by signs well
that's it that'll do it for you they
[ __ ] know how to do it - it's like a
hypnosis show they have these smash cuts
they go quickly from one person the next
and they there's just enough drama like
how are they gonna resolve this but it's
also no mind hypnosis because you're
just watching they're like the other day
yeah I had a salad and it was really
good and like why do I care but tell me
more about arthritis cuz my wrist hurts
we want to have a Candyland themed party
but with no candy well I want I want to
take them and swap them out on naked and
afraid
absolutely take them and just drop them
off in the jungle see how they survive
naked and afraid
ah that's it you know I mean have them
do something really difficult like a
tire just [ __ ] anything hard
their life is I mean it's really
interesting because I made sort of a I
don't know what you would say not an
oath but I decided to stop making fun of
Kim Kardashian who started letting
people out of prison yes I'm like that's
powerful she's real like that she's
really doing something like genuinely
good so I'm gonna stop mocking her only
you have to but it's and you know she
wants to be a lawyer
there's report well yeah she's in law
school is she ruling yeah she's going to
law school yes does she go there or she
do it at home
did she ever assistant do it and tell
her what the answers are gets the
cliffnotes yeah yeah yeah Kardashian
yeah he got the OJ off yeah or he helped
as part of the dream team yeah but he's
apparently the one that had the bag of
blood bag of bloody clothes you'd heard
it first so I heard oh man I don't know
if that's true but I don't you know and
you got a I don't know I can't knock I
can't I know she's doing good I talk
[ __ ] about him like it sucks cuz I have
like videos up from like years ago and
then I went to the of me just [ __ ]
on them and then and then I went to the
People's Choice Awards and I had my
friend Trevor rains like do this like he
designed this like amazing
country-western tuxedo but it was all
their faces crying it was so awesome
check out my Instagram it's so good it
was all and I sat and this waiter came
over to me he goes um you know they're
sitting right next to you right and I
was like [ __ ] I was freaking out and so
then they all come over and they're
sitting right there and I'm like oh like
my body look at your oh look at your
jacket
Kim looks up at me and she just goes oh
my god that's amazing and I'm like oh
and then she's like mom look and then
Chris is trying to turn around and she
can't and then and then Khloe's there
and then Courtney Courtney loved it and
then they start taking pictures of me on
their Instagram stories that I'm like oh
my god and then I got up to go say hello
yeah it was it isn't that dope that's
when I worked at E well they're not all
crying they just but they all look
walkie there's crying it's it was
awesome that's a great pic and then I
got up to go say hi to them and that's
when I security guard almost like
bodyslam me really hit the one at the
bottom you'll get a full one there's a
security guard they have overzealous
security guards oh yeah but after she
got kidnapped him exactly and I'm like
just what the hell are you doing you can
just you're 6 foot 4 you can just walk
over and like a normal person and sit
down you [ __ ] common or know your
place not only that you have pictures of
them all over your jackets a security
guard might think you're [ __ ] insane
by the way you look insane look at that
face what are you talking about that's
just a strong jawline look what's going
on here look at you that was yeah you
look like a crazy person
you definitely you look good though
thank you it's not bad yeah represent
for a ridiculous jacket I mean I wanted
it it was looking off it was stupid
I wanted it to be stupid and fun and
campy and
[Applause]